oh
it's so good it's really well done we
got in contact with the vfx supervisor
at scanline vfx
you have the normal challenges of these
gigantic creatures that you know need to
convey
like this massive scale fun fact scanlan
vfx does more than stick shots
i gotta know i gotta know is the stick
real
this episode is sponsored by skillshare
stick around to the end to see how you
can get 30
off your annual membership hey welcome
back to another episode of visual
effects
artists react we're going to be joined
by a special guest today we're going to
talk about some
crazy cg i'm sure a chunk of you have
seen godzilla versus king kong
most importantly we are going to get to
the bottom of this puddle about the
stick
wait i'm a little out of the loop what's
this stick so when you did the uh
episode of freddie on the snyder cut
there's a scene of steppenwolf walking
through a puddle
oh oh yeah that's a 3d polo right there
oh yeah
do you think people would be impressed
by the cg character we've been talking
about that but no we were talking about
the stick that he steps on it and
whether or not it's cg
wow cool that's really interesting very
excited
very important sam it's the most
important shot out of the entire
four-hour movie
okay sweet quick clarification about
that
we accidentally attributed that shot to
wetta digital they did a lot of work on
that movie but the actual company who
did that sequence
was scanline vfx and we got in contact
with the vfx supervisor at that company
and he's going to give us the real
answer fun fact scanline vfx
does more than stick shots they worked
on
a lot of godzilla versus king kong and
many other films you've seen
so i don't want to undermine them too
much by just saying they dealt with this
one stick look if that stick
is cg they deserve an oscar best actor
stick mr sticky
oh if she's not dead you tell her to
come down here you tell her to come down
here
walk right up to me and kiss me on them
death becomes her it's about these two
women that are basically immortal
and bruce willis batman used to do a lot
of comedy and was really good wait
that's bruce willis
yeah it is so
ilm now they just did t2 or they're
working on jurassic park
and this comes out and this was like a
very groundbreaking
vfx movie i just want you to do one
thing hell
you brought this on yourself
that was a sweet stunt that was a great
water like what a wire pole yeah yeah
today really shaped up and hurt did you
ever notice
how some days can start out well here it
is
oh what
how did they do that just suddenly
it's so good it's really well done that
that's that's a well designed shot
it's so well done how do you think they
did this shot my guess is that that body
is an animatronic body
and they did two separate takes one with
her actually
going up into the frame and then leaving
frame and they they merge those two
shots together
i think that's 100 true especially if
you look at the motion of her hair
it looks a little strange yeah it's a
little funny looking
yep nope you guys are exactly correct so
it's actually a puppet let's pop it on
wires
and there's no head and they're sticking
a blue screen element
of goldie hahn as she does the action
onto that shot
the puppet actually just has a funnel
for a neck and so they just pour the
water into that then it comes out the
stomach
a very doable and approachable shot if
you can match the lighting
and you can match the you know film
stock contrast it's a really doable shot
yeah this doesn't require a huge amount
of cgi skills this requires a lot of
effort on the
pre side of things you know the
pre-production actually getting the
model side of things a good camera crew
a good onset visual effects supervisor
to make sure the lighting matches up
so in this shot meryl streep is just
standing there with her head
there her entire body's on a blue screen
and this element here with her head back
like that
that's another element they've filmed
separately and you can even see when she
throws her head yeah
you see like the the rough haircuts on
the mat
it's really basic effects and there's a
little bit of like funkiness going on on
the neck where an artist is going in
there and basically like stretching out
imagery to get the like the neck texture
to like line up
there's definitely some rendered skin
there though where her neck actually
lines up with her shoulders
that's all cg islam this is like their
first skin shader they have a bit where
literally
her whole head gets lifted up off of her
neck and it's like her neck stretches
yeah look at that neck look at that neck
you also coke dude islam apparently uh
this was the precursor to
a lot of the shaders they developed for
jurassic park it was literally their
first skin shader
it holds up really well like
surprisingly so
it's there's not a lot of visual effects
from this era that truly hold up like
this does time and time again the
examples where we say this one holds up
it's usually an ilm shot yeah ilm was
like a beam masters through the 80s and
90s
and it's only been in like the 2000s and
later that other vfx warehouses started
really matching their skills vfx
warehouses
[Laughter]
i don't know what i said vfx warehouses
yeah no it's okay it's a renaissance
usually called houses
not warehouses i know but you know
whatever i've always called them
warehouses
because maybe it's because we work in a
warehouse we're working
in a warehouse we're a vfx warehouse any
building is a warehouse i wish to ply my
wares for yeah
any house with whales there's a
warehouse
hey guys well brian thank you for uh
taking the time and your busy schedule
to
virtually sit down with us and uh chat a
little about visual effects here
as you probably know we were gushing
about the scene
with steppenwolf walking through a
puddle and stepping on a stick
[Laughter]
and we accidentally misattributed it to
wedda
when we should have been attributing
that scene to stan line like who no who
knows right like
it's not like burned into the film you
know
do you know how long it took for the
post-production side of that scene to
take
scarf scheduled for doing everything for
zach's version was
seven months about a month of it was
de-archiving the old show and trying to
resurrect it we were done with the beach
torture before
we were done with the project so i'd say
five months
is a good guess for about how long we
spent on the beach torture okay that's
pretty incredible
like how fast you guys turned that
around yeah the
schedule for that you know was pretty
crazy and it was pretty exhausting to do
and like as we were
finishing i was joking like with all my
supervisors i'm like
yo good now that we're almost done let's
never do this again
we're all arguing here over whether or
not that stick was real and whether or
not that puddle was real
because it's like he's a cg character
interacting with what looks to be real
so obviously that can't be real
you can fake it to a certain degree by
having like boots walking through the
water but what ends up happening i feel
99 of the time is that vfx studios end
up just replacing all of it and doing
their own simulations
but this looks so real you don't even
think twice about it the puddle is real
although we did add some additional
interactivity to it
at one point in time there was a version
of the puddle shot where
we did a whole replacement but zach he
liked the stride that rich the stuntman
had done
so the final version that's in zach's
movie
it's a combination of real puddle and cg
puddle as well
so at some point you're literally like
fading between the cg render
and the real footage as opposed to just
replacing the entire puddle to keep a
level consistency
yeah yeah wow
that's crazy i'm betting that the stick
is real okay i gotta know i gotta know
is the stick real sticks in the
photography
oh it is real it is real it's too good
to be fake
i mean it makes sense with the giant
foot though like you can't just have a
small foot
you'd have to replace the whole foot no
you simulate the larger foot with the
initial ripple but the thing is
it's not like huge stomps that are going
to create godzilla waves you can still
mask that off
but like some of the mud comes up out of
the puddle too i love
the wet sand on that sequence and i
constantly was talking about it with the
effects supervisors
so i think it's funny that we're talking
about it you guys at scanline
good job good job with your wet sand
shout out for the wet sand physics
i love the wet snack yes exactly
please consider subscribing we'll never
do that again
all right the boat battle was rad this
is such a master class in
cg animation so many physics simulations
happening
all over the place
the amount of water interaction in
physics i believe that was a thing that
scanline was kind of known for
or like really helped them i guess kind
of get their reputation in the industry
i'd say that's a true statement like one
of the things that scanline had going
forward early on was their proprietary
fluid dynamics
solver called flowline and especially at
the time you know
that was pretty early on for doing the
gigantic ocean simulation
the company itself has a strong
background in doing these large-scale
simulations and destruction work
this shot's so cool i love how they hold
it and they stay locked and
you get breathing right there and then
goes back under i'd seen this scene in
the trailer
but i didn't realize that they're gonna
have a whole bit where like he's
literally stuck to the underside of the
ship
upside down in the water it adds like an
extra sense of tension here
what would you say was the biggest
challenge about that entire sequence you
know
you have the normal challenges of these
gigantic creatures that you know need to
convey
like this massive scale but the arena
that they're fighting
is also dynamic you know because like
the ships aren't fixed they're on
water that they can be on top of or blow
they both end up on the
carrier and like you know whether or not
the carrier could support their weight
you know like we
but it also it's see-sawing and it's you
know creating
ripples that go out and gigantic
splashes and then aerated mist in the
air
and they're both at that point they're
both wet so they are also dripping water
and you know at that scale you have to
consider what are drips and what is
missed
at the same time that they're fighting
they're destroying the aircraft carrier
and
the planes that are on top of it i love
the detail how when they're fighting the
actual ship
rocks backwards as they lean on it is
somebody hand
animating the boat first and then
basically taking motion capture and hand
animation for
kong and just kind of lining them up by
hand and then starting to work physics
simulations around that
or is the boat itself like physically
driven we would start off
actually and just keyframe out animation
for the creatures and the boat together
and then we would do simulations around
that we wouldn't
drive the boat with buoyancy stimulation
and stuff like that because now
if the boat is being simulated from
buoyant forces now that's going to
affect the animations of godzilla and
king
kong as well causing you to have to go
back and change those keyframes on those
yeah it makes sense to kind of
just to keep a level of consistency
there yeah get stuck in a feedback loop
yeah exactly
we did the big three-way fight at the
end between kong and godzilla and mecca
in the big shot where becca grabs
godzilla and drags along ground i think
that
we destroyed like four dozen buildings
and all the buildings we built like with
construction history so that they had
you know concrete and metals glass and
we put office furniture or apartment
furniture inside any of the buildings
where you would see it when the monsters
go in the furniture comes out yeah
i love how each shot is long enough
where you can actually like take in
what's happening
i think like as you know a director
slash editor and even
a visual effects artist it allows you to
really demonstrate your work
a lot better because you're not going to
catch a large scale simulation like this
if your shot's only
like a second or two long you have to
watch it for like
10 seconds to like see the effect unfold
now when you have a scene and you have
skyscrapers collapsing in the ground
getting torn up and office furniture
getting blown out of the rooms in the in
the skyscrapers
how do you get all of these pieces to
actually exist
in one scene together i imagine at a
certain point you are limited
physically by how much memory a computer
can have to hold all these different
objects
as much stuff that you can separate out
you do like if the buildings aren't
interacting with each other you don't
have to simulate them together right
like this little cluster
buildings is one thing this other one
another thing but
to your point yes memory management's
like a big problem
whether it's all of these collapsing
buildings you know you have kong with
all these like brazilian hairs
with debris on him and being clever
about scene management and memory
management
it is the only way to get through it at
this day and age we are reaching a point
where
there's incredibly complicated things
happening on screen and there's so many
different systems built to emulate
things from real life you know water
and fire and smoke and muscles and fur
and all these kind of things
in your opinion where does that line or
that goal of trying to achieve
photo realism diverge with the goal of
trying to make
a very cool painterly dynamic image
where do you find like that split what
exists for you
i think the answer that question lies
within the character of the film
there's definitely other films and other
directors that i've worked with who
you know you've shown something like
this is what it would look like they're
like you know that like that's cool that
that's what it would be but like i find
that very boring this should be much
more epic yeah you know and even pixar
does that too it's like there's a mix
between making something look
real and also making it look good
because sometimes real doesn't look good
you know i certainly have my opinions
about things and stuff but
like like ultimately the work that i do
and the work that our teams do
it's in service of the filmmaker and the
film that they're trying to make
fascinating thank you for uh answering
that question and uh
thank you for taking some time at the
end of your long
work day to spend some time with us on
this show and answer some questions
about visual effects it's
really cool to be able to talk to the
the expert and the people behind the
work
you know versus us just kind of guessing
on the couch here and saying that the
wrong company did the work
yes kudos to you and everybody else
that's scanline for the amazing work you
guys have been doing and we've talked
about
many of the different pieces you guys
have worked on on this show and
we will continue to do more so in the
future all right well thank you guys
all right so long brian thank you see
you all right bye
hey everyone we have really exciting
news for the first time in over a year
we have posted another great short film
on the corridor channel this one's
special though because it has
a lot to do with things you've seen on
this show things like virtual production
unreal engine motion capture
we've combined them all into our second
full short done in unreal engine it's
called
the cut scene and you can watch it right
now on the corridor channel i think it
turned out
really well and it represents over a
year of trial and error and research and
hard work
to try and figure out this new form of
filmmaking go check it out on the
corridor channel right now we got links
everywhere hidden all right
let's do this
what movies from the 80s and early 90s
still hold up today with their visual
effects let us know
in the comments do you like to learn of
course you do you're watching this
channel
we teach you all about things like
visual effects stunts animation
and a whole bunch of other stuff in
between because we are always learning
all the time as well
and one of the ways that we learn is by
doing tutorials and classes online
now if you are looking to get into that
there is a site that is specifically
focused for teaching so there's no ads
no algorithms nothing like that to worry
about
that place is skillshare you might think
that here sits on a couch
a man who does crazy visual effects with
crazy physics simulations but what about
making a pizza
well skillshare has me covered with an
excellent pizza making class
so whether you're trying to just get
better at something for a hobby
like your guitar playing kind of sucks
and you want to learn some new chords
or you are trying to improve your skills
for your career and you want to go out
there and land
a gig doing editing or illustration and
so on and so forth well
skillshare has you covered it's not the
matrix yet you can't just download kung
fu
but you can get pretty close just takes
watching a couple of videos and some
practice
so head over to skillshare.com to get
started the link is in the description
below
first thousand people to click will get
30 off their annual membership and if
you are
already a member you can even use that
link to get 30 off
your next annual membership there so it
works for anybody whether you are a new
user or returning user
all right back to the episode thanks
again to brian for coming on the show
i really want to have more guests on the
show to kind of talk about the actual
behind-the-scenes knowledge that goes
into making these movies
so subscribe for more guests yeah yeah
the end theme